Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain a South Korean
Tv mini series called “Nightmare Teacher.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
At the beginning of the episode, a high school
student named Do Do-Hee is standing before
a mirror.
She nervously assures herself that everything
will be fine the next morning and whatever
is happening is just a dream.
She is a student at Yosang high school.
The high school has its own website where
students upload pictures of daily activities
happening in the school for entertainment
and educational purposes.
Two students are checking the website and
reading the news about their teacher falling
down the stairs.
They also read about someone named L, dating
a student model of the school named C. The
website has hidden their names to protect
their privacy but the comments clearly say
that L is a handsome senior Lee Jong Suk and
C is the freshmen school model, Cheon Yoo
na.
Even though Yoo na is in her first year, she
has become very popular in the school which
makes the popular senior girls jealous.
Moreover, Lee Jong Suk already has a girlfriend
named Do Do-Hee, so the controversy attracts
everyone’s attention.
Do Do-Hee is with two of her friends, hanging
out in the cafeteria.
They have also heard the rumors about her
boyfriend’s affair with a freshman.
Her friends talk badly about Cheon Yoo na,
claiming that her beauty is nothing compared
to their friend’s.
Do Do-Hee thanks her friends for the support
but she is clearly bothered by the rumors
of her boyfriend dating someone else.
Her day gets even worse when the janitor removes
her poster from the notice board and replaces
it with the new one with Cheon Yoo na and
Lee Jong Suk on it.
The other girls can’t help but compliment
the picture making Do Do-Hee jealous.
They quickly recover and claim that Cheon
Yoo na looks awkward in the picture but Do
Do-Hee leaves right after.
When the girls are alone, they agree that
Yoo na and Lee Jong Suk make a better couple.
Do Do-Hee goes to the washroom to touch up
her makeup.
She has been bothered by her deteriorating
skin recently and doesn’t feel pretty anymore.
As she looks at her face in the mirror, counting
her imperfections, some girls outside scream
and run in a direction.
It turns out that the girls are following
Lee Jong suk, the most popular guy in school
and Do Do-Hee’s boyfriend.
Do Do-Hee and Lee Jong Suk have been having
relationship trouble for the past week.
The girls follow Lee Jong Suk around while
taking his pictures.
He, however, ignores them all and stares at
Do Do-Hee.
She looks away from him, clearly annoyed.
They meet at the rooftop later where Lee Jong
Suk suggests they spend some time apart because
they have been arguing a lot lately.
Do Do-Hee is in utter disbelief because she
had thought he would learn his lesson and
come running back to her if she ignored him
for some days.
She blames everything on the freshman Cheon
Yoo na and asks him if he is really cheating
on her.
Lee Jong Suk claims that those are just rumors.
Before he can add anything else, Do Do-Hee
asks him to not talk to her again because
they have officially broken up.
Before leaving, she declares that she broke
up with him and not the other way round.
In one of the classes, two people discuss
how many students have been not coming to
school for the past few days.
Several seats are empty which they think is
weird.
While returning from the rooftop, Do Do-Hee
bumps into a new teacher in their school named
Oh Ki Chul.
She ignores him, making her way to the classroom
but Oh Ki Chul turns around and looks at Do
Do-Hee in curiosity.
After lunch, Do Do-Hee again goes to the washroom
to touch up her makeup.
She starts to hear noises of people telling
her she is not beautiful enough for Lee Jong
Suk and that Yoo na will take her place in
the school.
Do Do-Hee has to remind herself who she is
while looking at the mirror.
As she recites positive affirmations to herself,
she gets a text from an unknown number.
Someone has sent her the link to a beauty
app called my cam perfect.
Do Do-Hee doesn’t think much about it and
clicks on the link.
It then redirects her to a beauty and editing
app.
She takes a picture of herself and starts
to edit it.
She makes her acne scars go away, her skin
brighter, and her lips fuller and pink.
She also edits makeup on the picture and looks
at it in admiration, thinking if only she
looked like that.
But what Do Do-Hee doesn’t notice is that
as she is applying several effects to her
picture, the effects also apply to her face
in real life.
While waking out of the washroom, she glances
at the mirror and is surprised to see her
beautiful face that was dull and colorless
a few minutes ago.
Even when she returns to the classroom, she
cannot stop staring at herself in a hand mirror,
not being able to comprehend what just happened.
Her friends notice the change in her face
and ask her what shade of lipstick she is
wearing but Do Do-Hee states that she isn’t
wearing one.
The other students are also mesmerized by
her beauty.
They take her picture and upload it to the
website where the entire school admires her.
Some comment that she might be wearing a lot
of makeup while the others claim the picture
is edited but the majority of the students
have changed sides from Cheon Yoo na to Do
Do-Hee, saying that she looks better with
Lee Jong Suk.
Later, Lee Jong Suk stops her in the hallways
and asks her to get back together with him.
He clearly regrets breaking up with her, now
that she has regained her position and popularity
back.
Do Do-Hee simply asks him to go back to Cheon
Yoo na and tries to walk away.
But Lee Jong Suk is adamant about getting
her back.
He even admits that he cares for Yoo na but
claims that he only loves her.
Even then, Do Do-Hee doesn’t accept his
apology.
As the last resort, Lee Jong Suk kneels down
in front of her asking for forgiveness.
Everyone around them gasps in shock.
An embarrassed Do Do-Hee reluctantly tells
him that she accepts his apology to make him
stand up.
Just then, she gets a notification saying
that her evaluation period for my cam perfect
app has expired.
It turns out that the version she was using
was only the trial version.
Because of this, the effects will only last
for a few minutes.
She immediately excuses herself and runs to
a bathroom stall.
She receives another notification that says
the trial has ended and her face goes back
to the original form.
Without hesitating, she texts the number back
and asks how she can buy the regular version
of the app.
Now that she has gotten the taste of attention
she would get if she were prettier, she doesn’t
want to go back.
Do Do-Hee hopefully waits for a reply holding
her phone in a tight grip.
Only some seconds later, she gets a reply
asking her to go to the consulting room if
she wants to buy the full version of the app.
In the consulting room, she meets the new
teacher Oh Ki Chul, who she had bumped into
that morning.
He confidently asks her if she liked the trial
version and if she really wants the full version.
Do Do-Hee doesn’t answer the question and
in turn, inquires how he knows about the app.
She soon realises that the teacher was the
one who sent her the text in the first place.
He reveals that he doesn’t know who made
the app but there are some conditions she
has to fulfill to gain access to the official
version.
A confused Do Do-Hee asks him what the conditions
are when she gets a little cut on her finger
out of nowhere.
A drop of blood falls onto the papers in front
of her and turns into letters.
Do Do-Hee has officially signed the contract
to use the app.
In the last scene, she is seen walking into
a mirror, unknown that she just made a deal
with the devil.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.